oregon is a smoky and eerie landscape
right now
and these are the evacuees you rarely
hear about in wildfires
the animals that owners gathered up
before they fled
now in a huge makeshift farmyard out of
the path of the flames
owners like holly howell are living in
caravans on site
forced to evacuate their homes and still
waiting for news of what's left
she and her 152 animals llamas included
have set up camp here this has been an
ordeal for the whole community
what are the last few days been like for
you all it's actually
regained my faith in humanity here
problem now is we don't know how many
houses are lost
the total number because people aren't
able to get back into their communities
so once that that happens you know we're
going to be able to start doing better
resources for people with myself red
cross is here i know helping out
everyone here has a story of escape the
morning that we all had to evacuate
um i had actually offered our house to
have people come bring their horses
there to be safe because we thought we
were
in a safe zone so we had like eight
extra horses come to our house that
morning
and by the afternoon we all had to leave
so all of their horses had to leave as
well as all of ours we were very scared
honestly we thought our whole town was
gonna be gone so
yes i called her two nights ago in tears
when i finally
accepted that i wasn't gonna have a home
anymore and today i have
hope that i think i might have a house
in a few days with smoke damage but i'll
have the house
they all know that this will last weeks
if not months
there are 1400 animals here right now
and that number is only increasing as
search and rescue teams go out to look
for the injured the animals who are left
behind
just as with the human cost and the loss
of hundreds of homes here
the real story of what's happened in
oregon is only just becoming clear
whole neighborhoods have gone and the
number of confirmed dead is increasing
firefighters are making progress aided
by the weather
but dozens of fires are still burning
into this we'll walk a president who
dismisses climate change as a cause
they never had anything like this but
you know it is about forest management
please remember the words very simple
forest
management please remember in the
wildfire zone he'll meet those who
disagree strongly
and for whom these fires are an
intensifying reality